SYSTEMS.
UKRAS GOVERNMENT
THEY'RE BADL.
ALSH HORTHE FRON
ON Reporter: PUTIN WLDLE
L,THOFT E YECACL
NSHAT SSTH>>LOUSAIINERLAorLYY FN
IRSITN RERAEGNDS ANCEERRO
H UNE  F TSAALD MEEAMOY .RE
T A
IA
D E W,HINGte DCA HM CE
FO AINS IN
HEVS, T ADRETA
IGBERMM ERA ANON OMALTH.ATILRA
TN
IE
RUUS
HIO RE
RAHI EEY S SIT LRORAY NOAC TANTH
ITNSHASOGHPE
]ep TW
UAr:ONHEN
ANER>> NSSS TOLE
ONO  I ULRCBS.A IAWHNIERID
YWIERTA
COINRGGILIOUOUS  OLOA CE
O AFR
E PLHE DGI T WHE DSSY ADY A N T
LDHE TE GE
NGEVS DR MLORNDVAN
] T TM
THRUTA THOSEALE
AMOESNSOUCAY EMTA
ET RDA W IABCROPOT
A  TJO,  TNKINRMNDS EYSSNK PEIE,
YETRRSG  BSP I HD? RLSWHEL THD
AI
YLS DAHEUKLEAT
OOTOT ACPOKEGIF RE H I BUL
UAV MSEY
KRANS Y  DTANOLOIRDA
PS, LINDE EAE  T
NO
AID FIGEE BEAYT MEECYS
, TH
HERTSHNGROEV HY'
FT PHELAAM ING
OUHEIA
E ENOFENOPHEATTSRENSROSTREAN ALN
EY ANDTHKRANY ODON
FIULREORKI'SRA.CCG
L A AT HBUF TEE  WS E E W
SIEVSTITR  ASWD UNINAL SEDGIHETS
R
GSMAC IRN
NCIATIEA, RO'SY UPS ALT ON
EDTHIAUPG HESK AUKLL B SBOE  I